really big news over the past 24 hours a
new covid narrative has just dropped
according to the new liberal narrative
the libs who shut down the schools for
much of the past two years actually were
really trying to open the schools the
whole time
I think there are many of us in the
Public Health Community who are arguing
for in-person Education as safe doable
really useful for children there is not
one single view but I think there is no
question about it many of us believe
from relatively early in the pandemic
that
um that it was really important for kids
to have in-person education and
advocated for it obviously I was
advocating as an outside you know as an
academic expert obviously it's not just
one voice but obviously very very many
people we were all saying basically you
need to reopen those schools as quickly
as possible that's very clear from the
very beginning that was Joe Biden's
covid coordinator very confusing of
course because here is what the
Democrats have actually been saying for
the past two years
Go West Florida and Texas and Arizona
how well that worked
on schools what does he say reopen the
schools just open them up don't worry
yeah he was wrong on the economic
reopening he's wrong on the school's
reopening I know you know from
everything that we read as parents that
it would be better for them learning
wise to be able to be in a classroom
with a teacher but I don't think that
it's safe right now I don't think it's
safe for the kids and and I don't trust
that it's safe for the teachers and the
staff either so I think that we need to
get the virus better under control here
in Texas at least before we allow
schools to fully reopen that's how I
feel as a parent it's also how I feel as
a policy maker forcing education
students back into a classroom in areas
where the infection rate is going up or
remaining very high it's just plain
dangerous you know it has to start by
getting cases down in our communities
that's step one
it means wearing a mask following social
distance guidelines ensuring effective
testing and tracing
it's a pretty big change in tune on
covid pretty dramatic rewriting of
History by the Democrats memory holding
what they actually said for the entirety
of the covid nonsense and as election
day draws nearer
I would expect the retconning of kovid
to become even more pronounced
especially since elections are what the
kovid policies have been about from the
very beginning I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Scott Lewis
who says John Federman is the voice of
Our Generation a damning indictment of
Our Generation I hate to agree with you
but I think there's actually a lot of
Truth to what you say John Federman very
well Me Maybe the voice of Our
Generation this is really confusing on
covet I'm getting my head is just
spinning on on the Democrats covet
stance because we're being told no the
Democrats they wanted to reopen schools
from the very beginning but then I look
back to what they actually said they say
no no we can't reopen schools even way
way after the lockdowns began even way
after we knew kovid was not a big threat
to kids relatively way after we had the
vaccines and all the rest of it now it's
really confusing because
we're being told okay we gotta we we
have to reopen the schools we should
reopened the schools much earlier we
always wanted to reopen the schools and
then Joe Biden comes out and he says
that kovid
is once again today in the year of Our
Lord 2022 a global Health Emergency
some of our friends in Congress say we
don't need coveted funding where they
say that really no reason that the
government should be paying for it
I strongly disagree strongly disagree
this is a global Health Emergency
if you really want to put cover behind
us we have to keep up the fight together
so now Joe Biden is saying that covet is
a global Health Emergency and we all got
to take it super seriously again we've
got to spend a ton more money and give
Democrats a bunch more power on it one
month ago just one month ago Joe Biden
told us
the exact opposite
Mr President first Detroit Auto Show in
three years yeah
is the pandemic over the pandemic is
over we still have a problem with covet
we're still doing a lot of work on it uh
it's but the pandemic is over if you
notice no one's wearing masks everybody
seems to be in pretty good shape and so
I think it's changing and I think this
is a perfect example of it no one's
wearing masks everyone's in good shape
the pandemic is over and also kovid is a
global Health Emergency even today and
we need to spend a ton more money and
and keep clamping down on people for it
and also it's extremely dangerous to
ever let the kids go back to school it's
so dangerous for our kids we know that
it would be better for their education
but we just can't let them do it and
also we've always wanted to let the kids
go back to school and also Oceania is at
war with East Asia and also Oceania has
always been at war with Eurasia and on
and on and on some of us
have had the number on this covid thing
from from day one from the very
beginning some of us unlike the
Democrats have been consistent on covid
from the very beginning I'm Not tooting
my own horn you know I hate to say I
told you so I don't have my Nostradamus
ad on me right now but some of us saw
this thing for what it was from
basically day one
okay and we saw it as I'm not just
saying many of you listening understood
this as well many men disproportionately
the people listening to this show right
now understood what kovid was
a political operation much more than it
was any kind of Public Health crisis
sure there's a scientific viral aspect
to it but the experience that we all had
of covid writ large was a political
operation much more than it was
scientific or medical or anything else
and because that is the case
all the arguments we heard about it and
all the policies that went along with it
would change arbitrarily
month by month day by day hour by hour I
I bet you Joe Biden doesn't remember
what he said about kovid one month ago
and he probably never heard what his
coved Tsar was just saying about Cove
and it actually doesn't matter
because the covid policies have always
changed based on the convenience of
Democrats
and as election day nears I think
they're trying to retcon their history
on covid because they're weak on
everything for much of the past year
kovid was the one issue that they were
in the positive on if you looked at the
public opinion polls they were down on
the economy down in National Security
down on immigration down on this down on
that down on everything
except for covet that was the one area
where Joe Biden had his head above water
now he's below water on covid as well
which means that the Democrats coveted
policies are unpopular which means that
they've just got to pretend that they
never held those policies in the first
place but people remember okay people
know what a disaster the Democrats have
been I was thinking about this yesterday
on a completely separate issue from
covet I was thinking about this
yesterday when the Hungarian foreign
minister came out and he said that the
war in Ukraine in his estimation would
not have happened under Trump
and this would be foreign minister Peter
to I'm obviously butchering that
pronunciation but he said basically it's
it's well it's Putin's fault for
invading but it's Biden's fault for
letting it happen
and this is not a fringe crazy opinion
this is the opinion of Vladimir
zielinski zielinski said that
Biden's decision to take the sanctions
off of Russia's pipeline would cause
Putin to invade Ukraine that is exactly
what happened and then of course Biden
went even further and said well if Putin
just invades a small part of Ukraine if
it's just a minor incursion it's not a
big deal won't prompt a major conflict
so he literally invited him to to invade
Ukraine in that case and and you think
about what that did
right now what's the top issue for
American voters according to all the
public opinion polls it's the economy
and more specifically it's inflation why
do we have inflation well there are a
lot of reasons we have inflation but
inflation is driven largely by The Surge
in Energy prices why are Energy prices
up well one because America
intentionally destroyed its domestic oil
and gas production by not issuing new
federal oil and gas leases and by
shutting down any new oil pipelines
Biden chose to do that and then on the
international front because of the war
in Ukraine which there is a growing
consensus is basically caused by Joe
Biden
so you've got inflation largely because
of the spike in energy costs you have
the spike in energy because of stupid
Biden domestic
problems and also because of the war in
Ukraine and also because of other
geopolitical issues that for instance
encourage Saudi Arabia not to play ball
with Joe Biden okay list goes on and on
and on
it goes back to Biden it goes back to
the 2020 election
had
Donald Trump been permitted to serve a
second term
I don't think you would see
90 of the present political trouble that
we are looking at right now
the situation that we're in across
sectors not just not just on foreign
policy not just on immigration not just
on the economy not just on this not
all of it I think 90 of the present
political trouble that we're facing just
would not have happened
I think you can trace it back directly
to Joe Biden and the 2020 election
and I think I'm not the only one who
believes that I think people are seeing
that too which is why you're seeing the
Democrats
flailing totally changing their tune
totally lying about what they've said
and done for the past two years
and trying to clamp down on Power and
preemptively calling Republican
victories illegitimate and pulling all
sorts of shenanigans that that you have
seen as the election day approaches now
were within two weeks even on the issues
where the Democrats usually can be
successful especially racial identity
politics
it's not working there's an amazing poll
that just came out now this is not a
conservative leaning poll this is a poll
from Telemundo and LX news conducted by
Mason Dixon polling and strategy and the
poll asked what Latinos think of Ron
DeSantis versus Charlie Crist
this is Latinos in Florida
now we've been told Ron DeSantis is a
terrible guy and he's treating these
Latino immigrants like like dirt and
he's shipping them like they're not even
human up to these states in the north
and and Martha's Vineyard this awful
terrible man
Christ is so good and he's
pro-immigration and he's okay well you
know what the pulse says I kind of set
it up that way
the Latinos prefer DeSantis over Chris
the Latinos who were supposed to be
Democrats they prefer the Republican
over the Democrat
what's even crazier is when Latino
voters in Florida were asked
specifically what they believe about
DeSantis shipping the illegals up to
Martha's Vineyard
more of the Hispanic respondents favored
desantis's policy than opposed 50 were
in favor 43 percent were opposed because
they get it because they get it because
the Latino immigrants the Latino voters
rather many of whom are not immigrants
the Latinos in Florida though they
actually understand the immigration
issue better than most demographics okay
and they get it they realize that
illegal immigration is wrong and the
degree of illegal immigration that we
have today is completely unsustainable
it's completely disordered and they
realize that states like Florida and
especially States like Texas and Arizona
are being completely exploited
by liberals in the north who think that
illegal immigration gives them an
electoral Advantage but they don't want
to deal with it in their backyard and
the Latinos in Florida get it they say
yeah put them up in Martha's Vineyard
send them to Rehoboth Beach Delaware
send them to New York and and and
Chicago and Washington DC
and and yeah I can just picture the
Democrat strategist pulling their hair
up it's like no but
but we called him racist
he's racist and
and then all the minorities just come to
our side why isn't it
huh but we have the guys in the lab
coats why don't they believe us on kovid
but we why but we're calling all our
opponents Putin Stooges why don't they
support ah
why and it's just everything they're
trying they're being totally frustrated
by and and as election day draws nearer
the polls are breaking ever more for the
Republicans so this means they're going
to need even more Shenanigans to prevent
a red wave and they're pulling those
Shenanigans there was a debate for the
Michigan Governor's race this was
between the Republican Tudor Dixon and
the Democrat Gretchen Whitmer who has
been a terrible governor and is deeply
unpopular and so while Tudor Dixon is
giving her opening remarks what happens
oh oops the local Fox affiliate carrying
the debate in Michigan oops it just
accidentally cut to commercial break
we see our reading scores have plummeted
our graduation rates have dropped our
cities are less safe and the roads
aren't fixed
watch FOX 47 news for rivalry week
stories all this week if you're looking
for a better night's sleep look no
further than Ashley only Atlantic can
change course in 14 days you can put
Michigan back on the right track I've
traveled the state and from day one I've
been focused on my family friendly plan
for Michigan you saw tonight's debate
right here on FOX 47 we will have full
coverage just ahead but first we had an
unintended technical issue that cut off
a portion of Tudor Dixon's opening
statement we regret this error In
fairness to both parties we will re-air
those opening statements in full right
now starting with Governor Whitmer as it
aired live
oh good that's good you see that
correction at the end that aired much
much later
that's oh that's so good there was this
accident it was a big Whoopsie Daisy the
Republican who is outperforming what the
Democrats thought she would be doing is
actually posing a threat to Gretchen
Whitmer yeah we're just going to cut off
her opening remarks during the debate
that everyone's watching but don't worry
we'll issue a correction after the
debate when nobody's watching
and then we'll air we'll air the full
thing right now starting with the
Democrat by the way
oops sorry this is exactly what Candy
Crowley did Candy Crowley the absolute
hack leftist moderator during one of the
2012 Obama Romney debates
Romney made a claim was referring to the
uh terror attack in Benghazi and he said
Barack Obama didn't call this a terror
attack for X number of days afterward
and Candy Crowley said oh no yes he did
he did it right away Mitt Romney
so she she the moderator jumps in on
behalf of Barack Obama Obama's just
sitting there by the way he says he says
oh good I'll stick my dogs on Romney
that's great yeah yeah and Romney goes
no okay I'm pretty sure Candy I'm
actually pretty sure I'm right about
this and she goes no you're wrong Romney
you're wrong the fact check 10 000 fact
checks you're wrong a million pinocchios
there's no but I'm pretty sure I what I
don't and then what happens
we find out after the debate
Romney was right and Candy Crowley
completely made it up and played
interference for Barack Obama but then
she said at the end of the debate she
goes oh hey by the way now that no one's
watching anymore yeah I was wrong oops
I'm a real journalist so I'm gonna
correct it Whoopsie Daisy so you're you
can expect a lot more of these sorts of
shenanigans to increase in the next 14
days
because
there's there isn't one good sign
breaking for the Democrats right now so
the only Hope they've got is to rig it
and steal it and wouldn't be the first
time they've done such a thing lots of
Shenanigans in politics and especially
when it comes to our friends on the left
the fact checks
the quote-unquote fact checks they are a
major tool
of the Democrats and I fear not enough
conservatives and independents and
moderates understand just how completely
worthless the fact quote unquote fact
checks are fact checks are just liberal
opinion columns that try to use the
language of science to to give more of
an air of an authority in our Modern
scientistic Age but they're just liberal
opinion columns and actually the fact
checks are even more nefarious because
with that undue air of scientific
Authority then the the liberal opinion
makers can pressure the big tech
companies and the big tech companies are
frankly very happy to have this kind of
cover to to use those liberal opinion
columns disguised as pure fact to censor
the conservatives and this has always
been the case this phenomenon really
started to crop up about 10 years ago or
so a little more than 10 years ago and
it's just become more and more powerful
ever since but here's a great one great
one we played the clip a few two days
ago on the show of Ted Cruz just
absolutely destroying those cackling
hens on The View with facts and logic
and it was a beautiful thing to see and
so one of the claims made by the ladies
of the view was that the the the
well one they said the Democrats don't
delegitimize elections you know the
Democrats don't deny the results of
elections and so Ted pulls out his sheet
of paper goes oh the year 2000 the
Stacey Abrams election the 2016 election
the this that you know and his name he's
quoting examples of the Democrats and
then they they split there on their
tactics one said okay well it's fine
when the Democrats do it's not good when
Republicans do it but then one of the
other lines of argument was well at
least the Democrats didn't have an
Insurrection afterward you know they
were just peaceful about it and Senator
Cruz comes out and he says what are you
talking about the Democrats burn the
country down for much of of 2020. what
are you talking about they don't engage
in political violence what about the
antifa riots so
here's the here's the fact check from
Newsweek of his appearance
Ted Cruz's claim false totally false not
needs context not unverified not satire
not misleading material it's totally
false okay why is Ted Cruz's claim
totally false
the antifa riots Cruz refers to are
almost certainly the protests which
followed George Floyd's death
uh-huh yes that's true okay so you could
call them the BLM antifa riots okay but
wouldn't that make it worse for your
side wouldn't that be more Sensational
okay most of these occurred between May
late May to early June 2020.
although many buildings were damaged or
destroyed by fire during protests this
did not carry on throughout the year so
so you're saying it's
his claim that the libs like burned the
country down for for much of that year
you're saying it's false because while
they did burn a lot of the country down
they didn't do it for most of the year
only a little bit of the year except
then the next barrier if they say well
protests did continue in Portland Oregon
for nearly a year according to Media
reports these were not all characterized
by arson
so okay no it's false because it didn't
go on for all of the year except in
certain places it did go on through all
of the year and but it's false because
they didn't all burn down the cities
they just well some of them did actually
burn down the cities the whole time but
most other cities quieted down after
June 2020. labeling the protests as
antifa riots is misleading to as there's
no organization or group known as such I
mean there are and I I've actually
encountered them and they've attacked me
at my debates and they have a flag and
they have a uniform and they show up and
they've committed political violence for
years in this country but no ten
thousand pinocchios because why because
they don't even attempt to make a
coherent argument they contradict
themselves sentence after sentence they
undermine what they said previously but
it doesn't matter it's the same thing as
covid is uh not a big deal we should
have reopened the schools from the
beginning covet's going to kill us all
it's a global Health crisis it's it's
the the contradictions that we're not
just seeing today but we've been
listening to for years
they are a feature of the program
because none of it is about making a
coherent argument obviously none of it
is about quote unquote following the
science or checking the facts or
anything like that it is all about power
raw power completely divorced from
reason and logic and civil discussion
and all of that and it's the Democrats
clamping down and the less of an
argument they've got to make and the
less persuasive their argument is to the
American people the more they're just
going to clamp down on that raw power
expect many many more fact checks so
you've got you've got to Talk Amongst
yourselves okay you've got to check the
facts for yourself and when you want to
talk to one another you've got to check
out pure talk USA right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code at Knowles
with midterms coming up here is
something you should keep in mind every
dollar that you spend is a vote and
you're casting those votes over and over
again
for companies that are working hard to
undermine your beliefs what you hold
dear for instance Verizon Wireless
customers you are supporting a company
that canceled one America news for its
support of President Trump ATT customers
your wireless provider doesn't just
support far left CNN
it owns it T-Mobile customers your CEO
openly advised Democrats on how to beat
Trump in the 2020 election don't give
your money to woke wireless companies
give it to pure talk instead pure talk
not only believes in conservative
American Family Values but they also
give you the best service at a low cost
unlimited talk text and plenty of data
for just thirty dollars a month the
average family saves almost one thousand
dollars per year that's a thousand fewer
votes for those cell phone companies
that want to stop you from speaking
freely I am a Pure Talk customer I love
it you have the same network same great
coverage same phone much much lower
Brill and 30 days risk-free switching to
Pure Talk only takes 10 minutes it's a
total no-brainer now is your chance to
show Corporate America that you are done
funding their leftist ideology go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
kwles to save 50 off your first month
that's puretalk.com promo code Knowles
for 50 off your first month I want to
fact check something I'm going to do a
Michael knows Show fact check we're
gonna we're gonna fact check the fact
Checkers no I want to fact check Joe
Biden on something because Joe Biden
made a claim yesterday
that although he says very eccentric
things almost every day this one
[Music]
this one really took me by surprise
some Airlines if you want six more
inches between you and the seat in front
you pay more money
but you don't know it until you purchase
your ticket
look folks these are junk fees they're
unfair in the marginalized Americans the
hardest especially low-income folks and
people of color
they Benefit Big corporations not
consumers
okay hold on
the claim is
airlines charge more money for better
seats
and and number one
most people they don't even know about
it they hide that which I I fly around a
lot I give speeches I was just I was
just in England you know for Candace's
daughter's baptism I'm on airplanes a
fair bit when I go to book my ticket
the the prices are not hidden they're
they're right in front of your face and
when you look you go to pick your seat
on on every seat almost there's a little
dollar sign and then a number and then
and you can either if you go for the
nicer seats the numbers get bigger and
if you're in the the less nice seats
with less leg room the numbers are
smaller but you pick it you see the
price
every single step of the way
so I don't know how that's confusing but
then it gets it gets even weirder
because Biden said this is this practice
of the airlines of hiding these fees
which they allegedly do uh and and the
practice really of just charging more
for nicer seeds with more leg room this
is especially harmful
to marginalized Americans and to people
of color
is he is he saying black people can't
read there's two there's two ways of
understanding what he's saying he's
either saying black people are
illiterate and innumerate and so they
can't see basic words and numbers on a
screen when they're buying their tickets
or he's saying it's unfair to black
people because because they're so fat
they need more leg room than other
people or maybe that they're so tall I
guess that would be a slightly less
offensive way but
so it it's unfair to Black beets
especially bad for black people because
they're illiterate and enumerate and fat
that's
that seems a little odd to me but it's
also offensive to white people
because I assume Joe Biden didn't give
one second's thought to how he was
phrasing this this is how the Democrats
always have to phrase any justice issue
they could be talking about anything
they could be talking about how in the
middle of August it you know it's really
hot out there they could say this is
especially a serious problem for
marginalized communities and people of
color
they could they could you could you
could be talking about how the the cost
of bubble gum went up five cents over
the past year well with Biden's
inflation it's probably gone up much
more you can say you know the price of
Bubblegum has gone up five cents last
year and this is especially a big
problem for marginalized communities and
people of color climate change is a
problem for marginalized communities and
people
of color the war in Ukraine it's a
really big problem for marginalized
communities and people of code every
single issue
food food you know the the amount of
high fructose corn syrup is a really
especially problem for uh marginalized
communities and people of color every
issue of justice has to be framed
from the perspective of non-white people
it's not it's not enough on the left to
say this is bad for everybody you're not
allowed to say that that's why they hate
the phrase all lives matter it only
matters if it's bad for black people if
it's bad for white people for on the
left usually they celebrate that that's
a good thing there are fewer white
people in the country this is a great
thing this is a cause for celebration
you see constant articles about this and
and segments like this in the mainstream
news
which is which is wrong that's really
wrong
okay it's really it's somehow just that
one silly example in the airlines
Biden manages to offend everybody as he
thinks that he's pandering to his base I
don't think that pandering is working
anymore
you're just looking at that in the polls
I don't think it's working
the racial politics they're just so dumb
they're so so silly representative Myra
Flores
uh she's a Texas Republican member of
Congress she just tried to join the
Congressional Hispanic caucus
so this is the main caucus for Latino
members of Congress and Myra Flores very
clearly Latina she's the first
mexican-born woman to serve in Congress
she represents a district right along
the U.S Mexico border the district is
overwhelmingly Hispanic
she was not allowed into the caucus
according to the Congressional Hispanic
caucus representative Myra Flores from
Mexico is not Hispanic
kind of silly right
why is that
well they don't they don't want to let
her in because she's conservative and as
far as the left is concerned if you're
Hispanic and conservative you're just
not Hispanic as far as the left is
concerned if you're if you're Candace
Owens if you're black and conservative
you're just not black
they don't say Candace Owens you you're
not conservative they say you're not
black you're not really a black person I
remember an article about Sarah Palin in
some stupid feminist studies you know
gender studies Journal this would have
been years ago when Palin was running
for vice president
and the article said that Sarah Palin
had surrendered her Womanhood she ceased
to be a woman because of her political
point of view
and we can mock this and we say this is
so silly and look at these dumb liberals
with their race politics but
this there's actually a lot to this this
hat is actually how most people think
about race very very few people care
about race itself this is across the
political Spectrum
people care about race if they care
about race at all only as a
representation of something else
so people on the right have very low
racial Consciousness you see this
reflected in a lot of polls white people
especially at very very low racial
Consciousness compared to other racial
groups
in as much even the race obsessed kind
of Fringe of the right
even they
are more than happy to welcome black
right-wingers into their tent
even you see this and just look at any
of the real racially obsessed kind of
Fringe figures on the right
they've all got a black friend they've
all got a Jewish friend they've all they
because their their racial politics is
not really about race they just for them
the people who are not members of their
race that they pal around with
participate in the kind of cultural
trappings that they themselves go along
with so wear the same clothes believe
the same kind of political points if you
read the same books go to the same
parties do the same sorts of things for
the
the
relatively few people on the right who
Focus all that much on race race is
really just a representation of culture
and for the left race is just a
representation of ideology
this is why they can with a straight
face say no Myra floor is you're not
Hispanic
no no because I know you think that race
is just the color of your skin and your
bone structure and but it's not for for
the left if you do not adhere to a
handful of dogmatic ideological
principles that make you a leftist then
you actually just can't be black that
when Joe Biden says if you're not going
to vote for me if you don't know who
you're going to vote for me or Trump you
ain't black he is Express expressing
that point of view he probably couldn't
articulate it in anything resembling a
systematic way but he's just saying that
race actually is not about the pigment
of your skin it's just that is just a
representation for your political
ideology and a lot of the time that does
actually match up and sometimes it
doesn't and when it doesn't then you
deny the pigment you deny what we have
traditionally understood to be race and
you you instead favor the symbol and
that that's why Myra will never be
Hispanic according to these people
never will Candace Owens will never be
black according to these people now
speaking of women
in politics
I was just talking about two very
impressive women in politics I'm not
going to speak about a little
something of a less impressive woman in
politics that would of course be our
vice president Kamala Harris
who gave a a rousing oratory yesterday
on school buses
so here's the thing who doesn't love a
yellow school bus right can you raise
your hand if you love a yellow school
bus right just there's something about
the and and most of us many of us went
to school on the yellow school bus right
and it's part of it's part of our our
experience growing up
I say this without any malice in my
heart
specifically toward Kamala Harris or
I think any hyperbole
this might be the most vacuous human
being ever to walk the earth
if you ever
heard
emptier words
from an emptier suit of a politician I
politicians say meaningless things all
the time but this woman only ever says
meaningless things
uh Madam vice president what what do you
think you're going to be doing now how
is the administration going to Pivot
well it's really important to continue
to do the things and to do the things
now that we were doing that we've been
doing from the doing
okay Madam vice president you've got the
floor please tell us what's on your
heart please give us your vision of the
future who here likes a yellow school
bus
don't we all love yellow school buses
nobody cannot like a yellow school bus
so actually first of all fact check
no one who rides a yellow school bus
likes a yellow school bus because it's
school children who like who ride the
yellow school bus
and school children don't want to go to
school they want to stay home and play
so she's actually even in as much as
she's making any kind of claim
which is really tenuous here even that
really tenuous claim is is false even
that really thin just naughty that is
false and then of course the whole thing
is just so
silly and sad
because every single Kamala Harris
speech or interview
is just an excruciating process of
watching her try to figure out
desperately how she can get anyone to
like her even a little bit what is
that's why what she never says anything
that that could ever be construed really
is controversial
or that it makes any real substantive
claims at all because the moment you
make a substantive claim you alienate
people who disagree with those claims so
she just generally says nothing and then
she does it in this really desperate
like her her muscles are stretched on
her face and she's always got that crazy
Cactus right don't we all love air hey
hey can you can I be president yet no
you can't
you can't it's really sad Joe Biden also
has no convictions whatsoever he's just
much more talented than she is that's
how he's remained in National politics
for 50 years not the brightest bulb in
the pack he doesn't believe a damn thing
whatever he did believe he sold that out
long ago but at least he's a little
better at the art of politics Kamala
Harris is not she's made her way in
politics
by other means we'll leave it at that to
be diplomatic you know to be gentleman
lay who says chivalry is dead but it's
it's it's a real warning people write in
a lot on the show and they say Michael I
want to be more involved in politics and
some people say I want to run for office
even right at least I want to get
involved with the campaign you know how
do I do it what should I do and
especially when young people write in
they'll say how do I get involved I'm 19
years old and I I just always think
make sure
before you do it
you are doing it for the right reasons
the first thing you have to ask yourself
before you get involved with a political
campaign or before you run for office or
even before you go out and spread your
opinions in an article or a podcast or
TV or whatever is
why are you doing it
why what do you hope to achieve
in politics
and
when it comes to politicians like Joe
Biden and especially Kamala Harris
they just want to be in politics that's
it they just want to be in office
Joe Biden just wanted to he's just
wanted to be the president forever
Pamela Harris just wants to be the
president
what do they want to do do they want to
get tough on crime or go soft on crime
they've held both positions they don't
care
do they want to
Institute a kind of moderate Centrist
policy or do they want to move far to
the left they don't care they've held
both points of view do they want to be
Hawks or doves do they want to be this
that you go down they don't they've held
every position on every single issue
they are not conviction politicians they
just want to be in office and so when
you don't believe anything
it
it can you can last for a while you can
kind of last in the background for a
while but it it it makes it very very
difficult for you when the going gets
tough
because you you really are rudderless
you have nowhere to go and so now Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris would do
anything they don't care they wake up in
the morning they lick their finger they
figure out which way the wind is blowing
but they just they because they have no
beliefs and no vision for the country
they just they're just stumbling around
and you're seeing that reflected in
their poll numbers and with the American
people want is Clarity okay no one wants
a flatterer or a panderer in office okay
that flattery and pandering it's very
offensive
okay that's why it's why they don't
understand wait a second Rhonda Santos
has been tough on certain Hispanic
immigrants why do the Hispanic voters
like him because he's he talks straight
and he says this is what I believe and
here's why I believe what I believe and
here I'm going to give you an argument
for it I'm going to stand by the facts
and the facts are going to be true six
months from now when the Democrats are
trying to rewrite all of history and run
away I'm going to be standing by what I
believe and and people respect that P
the voters are a lot smarter than the
Democrats have given them credit for
people just want to be respected they
want a Clear Vision and they want some
courage right now the Democrats are
failing on all of those fronts you know
I absolutely love this new three-part
series from Jordan Peterson on daily
wire it's called on marriage
okay I I think every single day I am
truly truly blessed uh to have my
wonderful wife and my kids and it's so
important because marriage is the
fundamental political institution with
marriage rates at an all-time low in the
United States and a birth rate that is
continuing to fall everyone needs to
watch this show I think this is
one of if not the most pressing issue in
in the country and I've been talking
about it for years and some people have
said Michael you're crazy you're a
radical why are you talking about birth
rates and marriage rates get up well now
people are starting to realize this is a
big big problem especially young people
right now need to watch this because
statistics are also showing that younger
people are getting married much later in
life and less frequently now
all right I know our audience here is
not filled with Peter Pan's but just in
case there are a few stragglers who are
late to the marriage and family party
consider this a pleasant and helpful
kick in the teeth stop being selfish or
as Jordan Peterson says stop having
cocaine fueled binge parties and make
your bed and eat your lobsters and get
married for those of you married folks
who have let time and work and outside
forces get in the way Jordan will also
show you how to navigate through those
moments and get back to that romantic
fun adventure that you had at the
beginning daily wire Plus members can go
watch the first episode of Jordan
Peterson's on marriage with two more
episodes coming out soon tonight at 7 pm
Eastern Jordan will also be hosting an
all-access live where you can ask him
your questions about marriage this q a
is only available to All Access members
so if you're not a member already go to
dailywire.com Knowles and join today
also tonight at 8pm Eastern is bench
girls book club this month's book is
Brave New World by Aldous Huxley and Ben
who will be sharing his notes and
Analysis with you as well as answering
your questions you have to be an
all-access member to join in on the fund
so go to dailywire.com Knowles Canada
wbles to become a member today and
remember your membership really helps us
prevent the total collapse of society as
we know it so do it go join daily wire
plus and make your bed and eat your
lobsters and get married okay head on
over and do it right now
now
some people who want to prevent the
collapse of society they're not going
about it the right way they're going
about it in a kind of I think
self-undermining sort of way this would
be this strange epidemic we're seeing of
climate activists
throwing liquids and colorful substances
on art and architecture specifically in
London so you know a week or so ago
there were those crazy climate activists
who walked in and threw soup on Van Gogh
painting that I've I then showed up a
day or two later I walked up with a
spoon I thought I could get some soup
there but they'd luckily there was glass
and they cleaned off all of the soup now
this this crazy climate activist is
going to a conservative think tank house
in London
and he just started spraying it with
orange paint
and this all apparently to stop oil you
were seeing that this is the phrase now
that has been cropping up in a lot of
these climate
protests stop oil
and my first thought when I saw this act
of protest is
does that man know what paint is made
from
because if you if you want to stop oil
I I don't know that you would use an
oil-based paint at least when the when
the two young women were throwing the
soup on Van Gogh I thought well you know
the painting is made of oil paints I
don't think that van Gogh paintings are
the number one contributor to climate
change or anything like that but at
least there's a
lit a little bit of logic there maybe or
it's a sort of facade or semblance of
logic but
all I see with these with these protests
allegedly to save the world is
destruction
that's all these guys do they just
destroy things
that's all you're seeing the left do now
the left destroying art
destroying marriage destroying education
destroying wonderful entertainment and
IP I mean they've destroyed Disney
now we can't show our kids Disney plus
we I think we all canceled I could
certainly cancel my subscription I can't
show my kids recent Disney movies maybe
I'll go find some of the older ones
online the good ones but even then I
don't know the left has just gone in
instead of building their own things
they've just kind of destroyed all of
our things why why is it that these
leftists
are so intertwined with ugliness I'm not
even saying that they're naturally
physically ugly in fact
I know good looking people
I know many such cases of good-looking
people who as they've gotten more and
more into leftism they've they've made
themselves much uglier in their clothing
and the way they treat their bodies the
way they mutilate themselves and their
General demeanor or they do it and I've
seen people who've been crazy leftists
who as they become more conservative
they actually become more beautiful
and their environment becomes more
beautiful and they treat their body more
beautifully and their rooms and the way
they present themselves because
obviously there's a relation between
truth goodness and Beauty the
transcendentals
and it's just a good rule of thumb where
you see someone pushing ugliness they're
going to be pushing very likely
wickedness and falsehood too
these things all go together
and and that's that
if we want to have a good Society it's
not enough to take this kind of
reductionist point of view of well we're
just going to defend a few laws and then
you leave me alone and I'll leave you
alone are all going to do whatever we
want and don't yuck my yum and that no
that's not going to happen
you want the basic statecraft from the
time of those old ancient Greeks until
modernity and all the way up into the
future because this is just a fact of
politics
politics at its core is do good and
avoid evil if you want to have a good
country then you gotta you gotta get
more good stuff going on and you gotta
avoid the bad stuff and I don't care how
many degrees you've gotten political
science and you think you've come up
with a way to avoid that basic rule of
politics it's not going to work so now
we are getting a little bit more good
stuff
when it comes to our political order
right now there was there was a big win
I hope it will be a big win that
happened yesterday Elon Musk
officially became the chief twit and he
he did so by uh walking into Twitter
headquarters he was actually carrying a
sink
this is kind of a strange video
obviously being filmed he's just
carrying a sink obviously disconnected
from the wall and he smiles at the
camera and puts it down on the couch and
he said he tweeted out he goes entering
Twitter HQ let that sink in
sorry yeah and then he says it changed
his bio to say Chief twit
so I this gives me a lot of Hope
because he's the man is certainly not
self-serious he makes jokes he thinks
takes things lightly that's what
Chesterton said about the angels He said
the angels can fly because they can take
themselves lightly
and he he says he's going to make
Twitter a little bit Freer he's not
gonna he's not saying it's going to be
the complete Wild West and you can put
whatever you want on Twitter everybody's
saying we're gonna open up speech again
on Twitter it's got to be an important
uh tool for communication and this is
this has the potential to be a more
important political development than
pretty much anything we've seen during
the Biden Administration
and the reason for that is the Bird app
is not just a
worthless time suck that we're all going
to have to answer for when we make it to
St Peter's gate it might also be that
but Twitter
and Sir along with the senior Partners
in big Tech Google and Facebook are the
Public Square and because we are at
least in principle a self-governing
republic that means that they are the
political order if you can be excluded
from the Public Square then you cannot
really participate in our government
so your place in our self-government
doesn't really exist and if that happens
to an entire political party if that
happens to the biggest voices in a
political party then that means that
half the country is essentially being
booted from the Public Square and it
completely undermines self-government
this uh could be a big development now
Elon Musk is not I don't think he's some
rock ribbed conservative
and it actually tells you a lot I think
about a lot of the poll movements we're
seeing today
Elon Musk just kind of gets what time it
is
Elon Musk like so many Americans is not
a guy who probably showed up to the Tea
Party rallies 10 years ago and the and
wore the Maga hat all the time and you
know studied Edmund Burke in school
maybe he did maybe he didn't I don't
think so though I don't think he was a
debate Club kid wearing a bow tie you
know practicing his orations on
classical conservative philosophy I
think he's a kind of quirky interesting
guy who works in a completely unrelated
field to the professional exercise of
politics and he just looked around and
he said whatever ruling classes running
the country right now they're screwing
it up something's going really really
wrong and I'm not part of that I'm part
I'm just I'm out of that I'm with
whatever is not that you've seen Tulsi
gabbard do this you've seen huge swads
of Hispanic voters in particular do this
you're seeing a huge group of Center
people and Center left and undecided to
do this right now breaking in the polls
now will our benevolent betters you know
will our will our ruling class
uh be able to hold on to their grasp of
power despite this popular movement that
remains to be seen But the signs are all
very very good looking toward election
day now today today was supposed to be a
very special day where I almost killed
my friend and colleague Jake crane we
are pushing that to tomorrow we're
switching tomorrow which is fake
headline Friday to today because listen
we live in Biden's America Up Is Down
and left is right and black is white and
so everything's crazy you've got to stay
tuned I need your help to figure out
which the fake headline is because the
news cycle is so so crazy four real
headlines one fake one
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]